cnn sarah seidner was in washington
state
reporting on the pandemic when it first
began and now
almost a year later she was covering
this recent surge when
the death and the devastation became all
too much
you know this is the tenth hospital that
i have been
i'm sorry this is the tent
i'll be perfectly honest with you i was
embarrassed i couldn't stop myself and
compose myself
i apologize i'm gonna try to try to get
through this
to do that live on tv and then that
feeling of not being able to control it
i was ashamed it's really hard to take
i'm sorry allison the 48 year old cnn
correspondent has seen a lot over the
past year
traveling around the country covering
kovid the death of george floyd
social justice protests and more her
breaking point came
while reporting the story of a woman who
lost her mother and stepfather to the
virus
the funeral for her mother was held in a
parking lot
it was rage that i was feeling rage that
people aren't listening they're not
listening
and they're actively doing the opposite
of what authorities are telling them
these are the experts trying to save
your life and they're not
listening have you seen the celebrity
action
jane lynch thank you sarah seidner um
jenna dewan please everyone take a
moment to watch this viola dave is
posting it jennifer aniston posting it i
saw biola davis
and you know what it did it validated
that we all needed a good cry
and that was my first really
good deep high that i have had in a
really long time especially since going
in and out of these hospitals
tracy ellis ross also showed sarah some
love
sending her a surprise care package this
is the nicest thing by the way
sarah's right back at it today she's in
michigan covering the possible unrest
there
back in the middle of all the craziness
because that's what she does